you already know what it is man bootleg
Capcom I'm backstage right now my dog my
day one homey man vic mensa cracker
hey man first of all congratulations on
it's been like a long like four year
journey since we first met I think I
think the first time we ever met was a
you were on tour Asher Roth with with
kids these days yeah you came up to the
station and did your thing man and ever
since then bro I mean it's kind of like
been an ascension how you feeling right
now I know like the new project is
amazing it's doing well what's your
thought process right now you feeling
good I'm feelin Amon emerges you know
had a little business out here on the
road think about the album think about
records so yeah I feel good how far
along is the album cuz you know I know
we've been waiting for it for a while
now changed I had kind of made like a
whole album and then you know scrapped
it
so I started fresh in like February and
try like 75% all those songs that you
scrapped are you ever gonna like can we
get maybe put them out as a mixtape er
it's done forever probably not yeah
which what's the direction of the AMA
because I feel like obviously with them
there's a lot going on there was you
know there was kind of something on
there for everybody but it felt you know
personal it felt you know there's
political moments on the project what's
the vibe for the album v for the album
is like kind of takes a lot of cues from
the last song of this Laguna ap the
title track Haley um is very
autobiographical and like story story
line based you know so just a lot of
narratives a lot of a lot of uh story
records was that like hard to do to like
that record is so personal you expose so
much like when it comes to like you know
drug addiction and your relationship
with your lady and all that stuff was
that is that something that like because
I feel like that might may have been
something that was kind of always
missing from from from from your music
maybe like kind of really getting to
know you as a person and
you really expose yourself on that
record was that like you know a hard
step to take musically no I wasn't hard
I was like I had written a lot of
records in the past like month or
something knows like February just I did
like 30 songs or whatever I did write a
song every day and you know it's not
it's not the same it's like like trap
[__] that make like five songs every
session they make the same song every
time and it
none of it says anything like I did a
lot of like soul-searching just with the
pen and like so it was kind of like
writing I record was nicely pretty easy
for me it didn't like take a long time
in a couple hours or so the video
shoutout to the homie Jake man that
videos thoughts on Jake is my favorite
video of the year though I haven't seen
like a really dope like one shot one
take video like that in a long time and
how like meticulous woman cuz I'm sure
how many takes did it take Fiat to get
it down because we were trying going on
you know try one whole time like we shot
it one day and then didn't really like
everything about it so we came back and
shot another day and that day it was
pretty easy because we already had had a
day of practice hundred percent um do
you still keep in contact with anybody
from from from the band from the I was
just bumping Trap House rock like maybe
two weeks ago though yeah me allocating
my solo yeah that was much it to me and
Nico had linked up on some [__] not all
that long ago but uh you know what I'm
saying and me and macey linked up
actually not too long ago too so every
once in a while we'll talk go so far
you've done so many festivals now you've
had a lot of dope moments on stage
what's been like the one like crowning
live moment for you as a performer
that's
and so far nah man its last Lollapalooza
performance like last week we came this
past weekend a lot of Palooza
performance I was it that she was like
thus far the dopest [__] that I've done
live
I saw video doing 16 shots it was yeah
it was dope man it was crazy
hell yeah is it harder cuz obviously
it's not as intimate of a crowd I always
feel like festival crowds are kind of
like you know like there's depending on
which artist you are there's like a very
small amount of people I mean it's in
your hometown no so that's a difference
hometown and it's late-night user like
daytime festivals sometimes you know it
has that feeling where it's like kind of
disconnected or whatever
yeah but home town like night like it
definitely still had like a lot of
intimacy and [__] talk about this uh
obviously you're you're a former
freshman cover alum there's been like a
lot of bad feedback with the new cover
which you know it is what it is I feel
like every year the cover comes out
people have some [__] to say about it
but what do you what do you feel like a
how are you did you dig out the you know
the the roster of of 2016 for the
freshman cover mm I mean you know Tokyo
could have made it you know there's some
guys it for sure
yeah I mean I felt like I felt like my
cover was a lot doper for sure I mean
that that's a given but past that you
know shout out to everybody do anything
as [__] I felt like this cover kind of
made hip hop look like it's really not
that good though I always tell everybody
like you feel like um it was just like
always you always got like you got like
a couple spirit [__] on there then you
got a couple rec one-hit-wonder [__]
then you got like a couple like just
swag guys right this was all swag swag
themselves all swag rappers it was
nobody was Janet to Devi so date Davis
Cup oh okay yeah I'm saying like no
matter shot at eleven people however
many people it is but as a whole unit
did feel oh I feel like nobody could
really rap on there um saying I'm either
like getting really [__] older I'm
I'm not on opiate so I can't rock with a
lot of you see yeah
but not man like you do so I've heard
you talk about like a lot of these new
kids and
it's in its true like there's been
freestyle videos like you know like no
shots because I dig a little Z and
little yachty certain records but like
we're like you know they openly don't
want to rap or they talk about how like
that doesn't matter to them and I know
you've kind of said that like a lot of
these new guys lyricism really isn't
necessarily like on top of the
priorities um
do you find that something that's less
is not like it's not like amalia like
required everywhere like you like
lyrical miracle miracle year you say
it's just it like not just i'm you know
i'm i come from a cloth of like artistry
that that values longevity you know
there and like substance whatever that
is not to say everybody got to be like
me and [__] have messages in their
music but you know them saying like I'm
just excited by music with substance
you don't say whatever it is it could be
like I was listening to you GK a lot
like the last couple days you know
saying it's like you GK were Street
rappers they were same reason it is yeah
I'm trying to live a [__] up tatta
living bad tight a grandmama tell me we
gonna go to church at um sell like
rinder tees I want my round like Street
[__] with some to say I'm just tired
of hearing it with not [__] to say it I
don't really give a [__] what it is
where's the pain at like yeah I mean got
no experience like you have no
experiences we've been [__] [__]
like driving cars and like you know I
know you only been even doing that [__]
for like a year
yeah later [__] act like they never
had no life before they put on a
first-gen this [__] well what happen it
not as real [__] haha
do you feel like um that's something
that works against you in today's
climate like as far as you kind of be in
like you know cuz I you know Jay always
kind of had that famous line back in the
day Ali lyrically could be Talib Kweli
you know ripping them sit down do you
feel like that's something that works
against you when it comes to like you
know maybe maybe having that radio
record or or you know kind of taking
that next step into the pop stardom no I
don't think so um cuz I got some radio
records in the can for so which is
summer which is somehow that new way
record I mean I didn't even but I'm
saying I didn't put
money Peter I'm saying like a guy radio
pop [__] this like dope [__] though you
know saying has nothing to do with trap
music you know I'm saying and not I
don't feel I don't feel like that [__]
works against me at all I feel like
that's that [__] works for me being like
a real actual artist somebody that
really says things because I value more
I value more like real reactions and
responses and being able to have an
input or like help someone's life or
situation and to have people relate to
me and resonate and respond to me I
value that a lot more I would rather do
that I would rather build a career where
I have people who whose life I touched
in the way that like power touched my
life when I was a kid everything just
like drop us on today it'd be number one
tomorrow but be like some [__]
saying you've already done I know you I
know you just brought that kid up on
suede that that you know that just found
you and it reached out to you but I know
that I know that like there are artists
out there too that like Kendrick and
Koehler are good examples of guys who
you know our substance and are also
[__] superstars yeah my and those guys
built up though yeah I'm saying
represent Kendrick encode didn't like
they weren't global off their first
[__] and I mean you know I'm already
global but they weren't who they are now
right we're from you know their first
release yeah um hey what's what's the
relationship like with chance cuz
obviously there's a lot made of that
Instagram picture they got his face
blacked out and then the Freestyle and
you know I know at the end of the day
it's always I mean it's all good it's
all good men do it all good are you guys
you guys are good because I guys booked
performing Lollapalooza I know he I
think future bottom out or something
like that yeah we're all good all right
that's good you heard it here we are
honestly you know [__] happens but you
guys got a lot of mutual homies and [__]
so you know I'm assuming you know you
can never be too bad oh it's not bad
it's not bad at all talk about the same
money crew Tokyo has been doing this
thing like like who else is down who's
coming out
yeah Joey's on tour with me right now
Joey
Tyler purp eyedrops
this mixtape you just put out super
[__] dope so um actually I need to
find puppy because we were about to drop
a song together like right now but it's
getting kind of late
or is this I was kind of late okay so we
probably won't do that till tomorrow but
yeah so do that tomorrow morning yeah so
uh yes sir Tokyo part out here when they
could come e he's coming up with a
project nope we got Knox fortune on the
road with us he's a producer artist who
did a lot of joeys project he was on
chance his album um yeah what I
appreciate about you man is like your
your passion for for social issues cuz
I'm a huge like you know like went to
school for political science and [__] so
like all the shows that's happening and
you know that is something that I'm
always passionate about and it's very
rare and seldom I I feel like you and J
Cole and I hate to bring up the same
three guys but like it's Kendrick as
well like really it made it a point to
really be passionate about speaking out
against a lot of the injustice is
obviously you rat a lot of the protests
in Chicago but like how do you feel
about where the presidential election is
cuz you know it's kind of there's
Hillary who's kind of like the devil we
know you know what I'm sayin and then
there's like you know possibly the
abomination of mankind becoming is just
the worst you know I know a lot of
people are disillusioned in a very upset
from Bernie's uh from his like well for
style kado convention yes said it in any
georgian [__] on yeah he get [__] on but
that being said i think what people have
to kind of realize too is like he made a
deal and it was like yo you guys have to
adopt a lot of my ideas for the the you
know the democratic platform and so a
lot of his ideas are in there a lot of
his ideas are right in there
and I support Hillary Clinton you know
what I'm saying because this is a real
election it's not it's not a fairy tale
your life it's not a fairy tale and you
can't you can't know how bad Donald
Trump is and not offer an alternative
you know that's that's that that's a
fake I don't wish upon anyone is to have
Donald Trump in control of nuclear codes
and with the ability to drop bombs on
countries just don't wish that upon
anyone that that's a bad look for
everybody involved
all parties so with that said I support
Hillary Clinton she's had you know her
share controversies of course um but you
know some of this [__] is some of it
sunday patty some of the [__] is petty
the email [__] we were really gonna keep
they know she's not even a good luck I
even Bernie like in the first debate was
like yo fam we're not talking about that
here I'm gonna keep talking about the
emails like that [__] as petty as [__]
yeah I'm saying like you're registered
to vote I'm assuming right yeah of
course what do you think are some things
that could be implemented on the police
side to prevent some of this stuff
that's been going on because I feel like
it it's getting like it's getting crazy
even like the like the videos that drop
that I'll see on Facebook that like
don't get any attention of people
conscious being dicks like in the end
yeah in cars I'll put a whole round of
your ass so fast yeah I saw you I'm like
yo fam like yeah or then there was the
guys who went into the dudes house it
was the wrong guys house and he mocked
them by saying oh well hands up don't
shoot right it's some [__] like that
like but like what do you what are some
things that like you think could be
implemented on that side that them that
can prevent a lot of that because
obviously it's it's terrible man and I
feel like yeah you know I think um I
think that we need to put a lot more
focus into like sensitivity training I
think the training of police needs to be
far more extensive there should be a lot
more money put into like psychological
evaluations straight
the people's background what they're
allowed to be police officers you
shouldn't be able to go through their
Facebook history and find sign some [__]
racist KKK type [__] but that's the
reality of a lot should be background
checks just like theirs back a JSON
dream background anybody like
psychiatric evaluations to make sure
we're not just getting lifelong bully
[__] psychopath so just want to exert
power over people because those are most
of the cops that I meet I'm saying and I
think that when cops murder kids when
they murder people unarmed black people
for the most part those settlements that
are paid to the family
they shouldn't be paid out of taxpayer
dollars they should be paid from police
pensions and police unions I think that
the cops can afford this like army
vehicle tactic gear share obsession they
should have a reporter pay up they don't
think twice when I start losing millions
of dollars every time they murder and
one of the main things that we need is a
citizen police review 100 council
elected officials that we put in power
that have the power to lock police up
you don't understand like they don't
need to be investigating themselves
anymore that's some [__] that's like
I go do a murder get out on bail and
then you ask bootleg keV to go like
check me out or you act when I think it
only goes like to go check the facts on
him like yo you boy they saying he did
it like interesting I think another
thing too is like like these cops are
getting prosecuted man cuz like I told
everybody convicted they prosecuted does
just get brother I'm saying that this
guy get Connecticut Invicta and that's
what I try to do but not all of them can
be innocent and Lanza obviously like I
don't condone what happened in Dallas or
Baton Rouge with the police getting
killed
cuz you know there was some good cops
that got killed um but when so many
people get murdered and nothing happens
to the people doing it somebody is gonna
be on the edge and they gonna make some
[__] up what you think bro light up you
can't tell me that they're all innocent
and that's what they're telling us you
know them say
and time after time yeah no convictions
that's just really like a slap in the
face
what need to restructure the entire way
that this that this system is put
together because it's really just the
modern-day arm of like colonialism you
right I'm saying and and police are like
overseers on plantations like yeah it's
crazy it's honestly and evolved in a lot
of ways like evolved Ku Klux Klan on a
lot of fronts except they let black
people trick themselves in the [__]
with it I'm saying like it's it's
[__] so we just need to restructure
talk about on the on the title track of
the record you talked about how yeh and
hoe were kind of um you know pulling at
you from each side trying to do a joint
venture deal explain like what happened
with that because obviously like you're
out of Chicago Kanye's [__] God out
of it like you know I'm sure growing up
as a kid that was like the dream
situation like I'm gonna blow up the
sign to Kanye or make music with Kanye
one of those things happen for sure but
how close was that to happening and that
was that being discussed like it was
usually about it you know themselves but
it's all family though of course yeah
any new music with yay or or anything
with home being worked on for the album
I recorded something with yay for next
project he's doing he wants to use in
compilation album crew was at the core
winter shader I actually don't know what
he was planning to use it for I think
he's planning on using it for that turbo
graphics Oh dope um but uh and and as a
record of mine he told me when to jump
off so I need to go link up with him I
just talked to him like right before I
did lava so I'm gonna go out there
catching you know your version of wolves
was the best version obviously I mean I
have to say that not just cuz you're
here
but like when the album came out and
like clearly there was a different
version it was either goes from Frank
Ocean show you know how he's like oh I
just was like yo how you gonna put have
my man out here on SNL that's fantastic
um but yo man so hopefully the album
comes out is are you changing the name
of the album mm-hmm so it was supposed
to be traffic right yeah so so I mean is
do you have the name I had a name I'm
like I'm not
I can tell me I know you're not gonna
tell so the so traffic is dead it it's
going to just hang out on your hard
drive any like other I mean I would
appreciate about kind of how you
involved I'm like working with guys like
cam and then like you know you were
working with like Skrillex and I think
that that you kind of did a really good
job of bridging his sound into what you
do are who are some of the producers
that you're trying to work with on the
new project I need to get up with Just
Blaze yo fam all I want is just blaze to
do like Josh should I want I want just
blaze to do like an entire EP for like I
just want just an artist that I spoke
with to get in his place to come [__]
with yes so and then for ro but I mean
just Pleasant for oh you know I'll be
straight Mike Dean has some stuff on a
stretcher
poppy beets did a lot of it smoke oh oh
no you know just my my house guys yeah
collaboration wise we talked about the
XXL cover how its kind of its kind of
week this year we're some new artists
besides the save money crew that that
you're [__] with that you've heard
that you're like okay like I see what
you're doing the [__] would be Bieber le
okay my [__] were Rory
Rory's dope for sure um good thing I
[__] I think I just wrote down somebody
I thought was good the other day I don't
know if they're new des Eaux dev Hines
okay love that hot [__] blood orange
yeah you know saying that not not really
a lot of rappers I'm not really filling
them just into a lot of bands and [__] a
lot a lot of rock [__] or worth it yeah
I may listen to a lot of rap - I just
don't listen to new rap just UGK there's
some classic ill [__] I'll listen I mean
I was listening to Gucci new album
coochie I'm is cool there's some [__] on
there but sure yay
Gucci I'm got some [__] on there
foreshortened yeah yeah what's your
favorite if you had to like if someone
was like yo Vic imma you're gonna have
to do a three-year bid in prison god
forbid you can take a ipad with five
albums on her iPod with five hours on
which five albums would you put on there
I would be pressed okay so I had to take
five hours ah oh no I'm kind of I'm kind
of bleh it's like I know - like it's
ematic and late registration for me
outside of that it'd be tough maybe
Gangstar moment of truth I'll probably
take D'Angelo uh Lulu Haruka yeah I'll
take voodoo I don't really have anything
on my phone but it might make give me
some ideas I would take em could you
take a J album yeah I think which one I
take the blueprint one okay that's my
[__] I'll take the blueprint one um yo
you got some fire all night on the
iPhone this random [__] yours like I
don't even know how that [__] ended up
on here I would take this like soul
album by Nancy Wilson called I know I
love him okay all right that out [__] is
crazy though I probably took the Low End
Theory great great roots album or I'm
sorry great tribe album sorry about them
um I'm curious I just saw on your on
your phone this is just a random hip-hop
fan what I think would sound dope I saw
you had some dead prez on your phone I
think you and Dad pressure just [__] I
think that she would be ill I'm such a
big tub but what his dick man would be
lit I'm not to be crazy weird Apple look
new music coming out go support is there
gonna be 16 shots video that needs to
happen I feel like it it's it's like
overdue but I had to come out here and
do these shows so and then nube is kind
of like the record you guys are kind of
working the radio yeah great record by
the way
it's gonna be visual for that um we'll
see I think just talk about some just
for the record - I think like the game
changer for you is that voice man I
think like we were talking about like
you know you said you got radio records
that aren't necessarily like some turnip
[__] your voice is like I think we'll
put you over the top and radio
eventually
yo Vic Mensa my guy I'm proud of others
good seeing you man I love you already
know